Ask about VRAYLAR.
>> Tucker: WE'VE SOUND THE
ALARM ON THE SHOW OF THE
DECREPIT STATE OF NEW YORK
CITY'S PENN STATION.
IT'S FILTHY, FULL OF WASTE AND
WE SAID AS MUCH ON THE SHOW.
HAVE YOU BEEN TO PENN STATION
RECENTLY?
IT'S LIKE A HOMELESS SHELTER
IT'S DISGUSTING.
YOUR GIVING SPEECHES, TRUMP IS
BAD AND IGNORE THE GUY LIVING
UNDER THE ATM MACHINE OR
RELIEVING HIMSELF -- HAVE YOU
BEEN IN THE MEN'S ROOM AT
PENN STATION?
TO OUR SURPRISE AND HAPPINESS,
AMTRAK CALLED US AND SAID THEY
HAD REVAMPED THE PLACE AND
CLEANED UP ITS MEN'S ROOMS.
WE WANTED TO SEE IF THAT WAS
TRUE SO WE SENT THE INTREPID
BRETT MARSON TO INVESTIGATE,
HERE'S WHAT HE FOUND.
>> IT'S NOT EVERY DAY YOU GET AN
INVITE FOR AN EXCLUSIVE
ONE-ON-ONE TOUR OF THE MEN'S
BATHROOMS IN NEW YORK'S
NESTORIUS PENN STATION, SO EAGER
TO SHOW US THEIR NEWLY RENOVATED
BATHROOMS, THEY THREW UP THE
POLICE BARRICADES AND CLEARED
OUT THE CUSTOMERS.
AND HAD US MEET THEM AT
3:00 A.M.
HOW COULD WE PASS THAT UP IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT WE GOT A
VERY CLOSE UP AND PERSONAL DEMO
OF THE NEW ALL IN ONE SINKS.
>> YOU CAN SELECT THE WATER.
TECHNOLOGY IS FUN.
>> PENN STATION IS NOTORIOUS FOR
ITS PROBLEM WITH HOMELESSNESS,
THE DOWN AND OUT DRUG ABUSERS
COME HERE EACH NIGHT, THE PLACE
LITERALLY BECOMES A HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENT IN THE WINTER.
GUESS WHERE THEY GO TO BAIT EACH
NIGHT, THAT'S WHEN WE NOTICED
THE NEW SINK DESIGNS.
>> THESE AREN'T VERY DEEP, I'M
GUESSING YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
SPLASH WATER, YOU PROBABLY GOING
TO SPLASH WATER IN YOUR FACE.
>> NO CHANCE OF GETTING AN ARM
OR LEG UNDER THAT THING.
AMTRAK WAS EASIER TO TELL US HOW
THEY EVOLVED, HOW PENN STATION
IS BECOMING MORE OF A
DESTINATION TRANSIT HUB AND LESS
OF A THIRD WORLD ISLAM.
>> YOU DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO FEEL
THAT WAY OR HAVE THAT OPINION,
YOU WANT TO INVOKE A GREAT
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU'RE NOT ONLY
COMING FROM THE TRAIN BUT YOU'RE
GETTING OFF THE TRAIN AS WELL.
THE JOURNEY DOESN'T END OFF THE
TRAIN.
>> EXIT THE FANCY NEW RESTROOMS.
AND AT THE SAME INTIMIDATING
PENN STATION.
EXIT ON SEVENTH AVENUE, THERE'S
PEOPLE SLEEPING ON THE FLOOR.
OPPOSITE MADISON SQUARE GARDEN,
THOUSANDS OF HOMELESS PEOPLE
CAMPING OUT FOR THE NIGHT OTHERS
SEEMINGLY UP TO NO GOOD AT ALL.
NOT EVERYONE DISLIKES PENN
STATION.
>> IT'S A NICE STATION, GOOD FOR
DEPARTURES, GOOD FOR
DESTINATIONS.
>> WE HAD ONE LAST QUESTION FOR
THE AMTRAK GUY.
>> IS THAT PART OF THE NOSTALGIA
WAS MAKE IT ALWAYS SMELLS LIKE
WHEN YOU'RE WALKING AROUND.
>> WERE LOOKING AT EVERYTHING TO
MAKE A BETTER CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE.
>> A BETTER CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE,
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO GET
IN THAT RESTROOM AS WELL AS THE
WOMEN'S RESTROOM NEWLY RENOVATED
AT PENN STATION.
AS FOR THE REST OF PENN STATION,
THAT TRANSIT HUB IN THE MIDDLE
OF MANHATTAN ONE OF THE MOST
EXPENSIVE CITIES IN THE COUNTRY,
ONE OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE CITIES
IN THE WORLD, IT IS STILL THE
SAME OLD DUMP AS WE SAW AT 3:00
IN THE MORNING.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF IT'S THREE
IN THE MORNING OR THREE IN THE
AFTERNOON OR RUSH HOUR, OR A
WEEKEND DAY, PENN STATION IS
ALWAYS DISGUSTING AND IT'S
EMBARRASSING.
WHEN YOU TAKE AMTRAK FROM D.C.
YOU GET ON THAT BEAUTIFUL
UNION STATION WHICH IS THIS
GORGEOUS TRAIN STATION THAT'S
BEEN RESTORED, GRAND CENTRAL
STATION IF YOU GO IN THE MAIN
HALL, YOU GET UP AT PENN STATION
IT FEELS LIKE YOU HAVE ARRIVED
AT SOME TERRIBLE HELL SCAPE AND
MAYBE THE MONKEYS DID WIN, THE
APES FROM "PLANET OF THE APES,"
YOU'RE WALKING OUT LIKE WHAT IS
THIS?
>> Tucker: WE SHOULD HAVE MORE
SELF-RESPECT THAN THAT.
>> IT'S EMBARRASSING, TOTALLY
EMBARRASSING.
CONGRATS TO AMTRAK FOR NEW
BATHROOMS BUT THERE'S A LOT MORE